let's bring in cbs news medical
contributor dr eight david agus now
david good morning
david what do we know about how
effective the current vaccines are
against the delta variant
anthony what we know is that two shots
of moderna or pfizer
provide good but not perfect protection
against the delta varian that is about
88 to 90
protection if you've been exposed to the
delta variant
we're seeing some breakthroughs in
israel there were breakthroughs in
elderly who got vaccinated very early
and some of their immunity went down but
in general we are protected from the
delta variant to the present time
what about the johnson and johnson
vaccine david because some experts are
saying that
that people may need to get a pfizer or
modern
in effect booster shot as well as that
first
johnson johnson shot
it's a key question you know early on
jnj took a bold decision of putting a
higher dose
of a vaccine in one shot because
they were thought much of the population
be reticent to get two shots
it worked against the original variance
of the
virus right now we just don't know the
cdc has the data
that is who has been hospitalized and
what vaccine they got we are anxiously
awaiting for them to release that data
so we will know if those people need to
get an rna vaccine about six months
after their original shot
so we're all on pins and needles waiting
in the public health community
and obviously patients who got that j
vaccine are watching anxiously tv
also hopefully for some news a new study
david found the pfizer and modern
vaccines could
offer long-term immunity
yeah i mean so you have to take these
with a little bit of caution is what
they showed is that
six months out the immunity was better
than thought
um and looked very good but those were
to the original strains of the virus
the virus is changing so likelihood is
especially the elderly will need
a booster such sometime in the late fall
and people with medical conditions
everybody else the jury is out this was
positive data immune responses look
really robust
but i'm not sure it's enough for all of
the variants david what do you make of
la county's recommendation that people
where fully vaccinated people
wear masks indoors again
well i think what it reflects is is that
not everybody is vaccinated
and you know there are people going out
without vaccines
and we have to protect everybody and
stop the spread of the virus
so i think it's a reasonable it's not a
mandate it's a recommendation and i
think it's a reasonable recommendation
at the present time you know we have two
americas those vaccinated
and those not and i i they're going to
be different trajectories for both
and that certainly worries me all right
david agus thank you very much dr david
agus